today on the matt walsh show an olympic
athlete turns her back on the flag as
the national anthem has played
there's a catastrophic lack of gratitude
in this country it's become a real
epidemic in my opinion and it's this is
just the latest symptom of it so we'll
talk about that also five headlines
including
peaceful protesters exercise their free
speech rights by defacing a
george floyd statue also a
self-proclaimed intellectual in msnbc
calls white conservatives maggots
and then apologizes sort of and in our
daily cancellation we'll discuss the
lgbt activists
and people in the media who are very
offended and upset that the latest pixar
film about two young boys
is not a gay romance all of that and
much more today on the matt walsh show
now we check in with charity mobile you
know i've been a charity mobile customer
myself for a long time now and i
couldn't be happier with the service
because it's a great service but also i
know
that i'm supporting a pro-life phone
company a
pro-life cause i'm supporting a company
that's actually on my side
in the culture and that's why charity
mobile is called the pro-life phone
company because five percent of your
monthly plan price goes to the pro-life
pro family charity of your choice
um and there's a lot there's a lot of
other reasons to join charity mobile
like you get new activations and
eligible accounts get a free cell phone
with free activation and free shipping
there's no contracts enough to deal with
any termination fees or anything to deal
with with uh with some other companies
and there's also no risk with a 30-day
guarantee so you might as well try it
out
and see if you like it i think you will
another thing you'll probably like is
the live customer service
based right here in the usa you also get
a free app to monitor
your usage you get free usage alerts
which really come in handy
and all the while you're helping to
build a culture of life in america while
supporting a pro-life phone company
so call them at 1-877-474-3662 or chat
with them online at charitymobile.com
so it's not often that i begin the show
by quoting ancient
roman philosophers but today this quote
comes immediately to mind cicero
at least according to a facebook meme
that i saw once said
gratitude is not only the greatest but
is also the parent of all the other
virtues
that's the more famous version of the
quote anyway actually the full version
is better
he said in truth o judges while i wish
to be adorned with every virtue
yet there is nothing which i can esteem
more highly than the being and appearing
grateful for this one virtue is not the
only not only the greatest
but is also the parent of all the other
virtues now the facebook meme didn't
tell me why he said this but it's not
difficult to imagine
how one might defend that claim
that gratitude is the parent of all
virtues many other virtues seem to be
contained
in gratitude in order to be truly
grateful to
someone or for something you have to be
humble you have to be prudent
you must be kind gratitude is the sister
of generosity
generosity is in the giving gratitude is
in the receiving
if one is present in the interaction but
not the other there's a risk that soon
both will be lost
you know if you've ever tried to be
consistently generous to a habitually
ungrateful person
you know how this works gratitude is
certainly not something that a deeply
selfish person can experience
a selfish and entitled person won't be
grateful for anything because they
believe that everything they're given
was already owed to them
and whatever it is it's not enough
anyway they're never satisfied let alone
grateful
and this is why as parents we spend so
much time
teaching gratitude to our children after
you take your child out for ice cream
or you go to the zoo or you put dinner
on the table there's that common refrain
i know i say it all the time
what do you say and the child prompted
shouts thank you until hopefully he
doesn't need to be prompted anymore
now this this isn't a simple matter of
teaching good manners though it is that
also of course
but on a deeper level you're instilling
gratitude
and it does have to be instilled
inculcated taught
it doesn't come on its own children are
naturally inclined to take things for
granted to think well
you know of course mommy and daddy gave
me this that's their job their mommy and
daddy
we have to teach them that much of what
we do for them is
above and beyond the mere fulfillment of
a job we don't have to give them ice
cream we do that because we love them
and for that they should be grateful and
even the things
that are fulfilling the job making them
dinner for example
putting a roof over their heads that
should still be met with gratitude
this is a lesson we teach them for their
own sake not for ours
grateful people are good people they're
happy people
they're well adjusted people grateful
people have friends they get hired for
jobs they enjoy
life so it is then no surprise
that in a country where so many people
are miserable and angry and depressed
all the time
there's also a catastrophic lack of
gratitude
which brings us finally to a woman named
gwen berry
this past weekend was the u.s olympic
trials for track and field one of the
track and field events is the hammer
throw now
unfortunately and i just learned this
today um
because i don't really watch the
olympics they're not throwing hammers
like the ones you find at a home depot
as fun as that would be i'd imagined
like a toolbox and they're just chucking
hammers maybe at each other that'd be
fun
instead it's like the shot put except
with kind of a sling
gwen berry is one of the athletes who
competed in that event
and she managed to achieve third place
behind a woman named deanna price in
first place and brooke anderson
in second now as it happens deanna price
had a record-breaking day of chucking
the metal ball around
she actually was she i think she broke
her own record which she had set before
and
but that achievement was overshadowed by
third place barry
who while standing on the podium turned
her back on the flag
and began visibly pouting as the
national anthem was played
towards the end of the song she covered
her head with a with a black t-shirt
that read
activist athlete this is all it takes to
be an activist these days
of course all you need to do is stand
around like a pouty sullen child
which at least you didn't burn anything
uh i guess we could be grateful for that
speaking of gratitude
perhaps she's saving that for when the
olympics actually start
now after her little stunt barry
explained to reporters that she reacted
that way to the anthem
because she considered it a personal
affront
that it had been played at all this is
this is her quote the quote from her she
said quote
i feel like it was a setup i feel like
they did that on purpose
and i was pissed to be honest i was
thinking about what should i do
eventually i just stayed there and i
just swayed i put my shirt over my head
it was real disrespectful
i know they did that on purpose but
it'll be all right
i see what's up now to be clear
she's not saying that her turning her
back was disrespectful
which it was she's saying that they were
disrespecting
her by playing the anthem in the first
place
she felt personally disrespected by the
anthem
this woman is not only an unpatriotic
whiny disgusting brat
but she also believes the world revolves
around her they play the anthem every
day during the trials at around that
time
yet if it plays on the day that she's
competing it must be some kind of
personal attack against her but it's no
surprise she has this attitude grateful
people
tend to possess all the other virtues
ungrateful people in contrast tend to
possess
none at all she's ungrateful so of
course she's also
self-centered and petty and everything
else now of course
in a healthy country an olympic athlete
who turns her back on her own flag
would be kicked off the team and
publicly shamed and reviled for being
the disgraceful embarrassing jackass
that she is
but we're not a healthy country so
instead she will be and already has been
lionized as some sort of civil rights
hero standing up against
oppression what sort of oppression
though i mean what exactly is she so
angry about
in what precise way has this person been
at all victimized what is she mad about
what's the problem
that's never made clear out of all these
people
claiming to have some deep grievance
against the united states
none of them can ever explain what it is
they could talk about history they could
talk about things that happened 200
years ago
but they can't explain what's happened
to them
what did this country do to you
specifically that's made you feel this
way
that's because their grievance doesn't
stem from anything
external it comes internally from their
own lack of gratitude
this country has given gwen berry
everything now it even gives her an
international forum
to complain about it to complain about
her country
but it's not enough nothing is ever
enough her attitude similar to the
attitude of so many others
is um is not that she's grateful for all
that she's been given
the freedom she's been afforded the
luxury she's and she enjoys
and yet she still recognizes the
problems in our society and wishes to
fix them that's one thing
i mean it's one thing if you say i'm i'm
very grateful for this country i love
this country uh
but it's not a perfect country obviously
no country is perfect
and so here are some problems we should
fix
that's that's a perfectly fine attitude
anyone should have that attitude
nobody is saying that in order to be
patriotic you have to think that your
country is flawless
i certainly don't
but the problem for her is that she sees
only darkness and horror that's all she
sees
she can't even bear to look at the flag
can't bother to stand for two minutes
with her hand on her heart
she won't even give that to her country
she will give her country nothing in
exchange for the everything
that it has given to her because
although her life is good and far better
than it would be literally anywhere else
on earth which is why she chooses to
stay here
rather than move somewhere else
even so it's not perfect and if she
hasn't been given a perfect life
then she won't be grateful for a good
but imperfect one
this is a woman who again like so many
others was never taught gratitude
as a child we can assume and it's
probably too late to teach it now but
even so
maybe we should try so so gwen what do
you say
what do you say to america you say thank
you
and you do it with your hand over your
heart looking at the flag
now let's get to five headlines
well if you're a business owner i don't
have to tell you there are a lot of
challenges that come
with being a business owner very
rewarding to be your own boss and
everything but a lot of challenges come
with one of them
the most basic challenge probably is
finding the right person
for your role uh the role that you're
trying to fill and that's why you need
zip recruiter
you know hiring can feel like searching
for a needle in a haystack sure you
could post your job to some
job board but then all you can do is
just hope that the right person comes
along and stumbles across it out there
in the wilderness of cyberspace
uh why do that when you can just use
ziprecruiter
for free at ziprecruiter.com walsh when
you post a job on zip recruiter it gets
sent to over a hundred top
job sites with one click then zip
recruiters matching technology finds
people
with the right skills and experience for
your job and it actively invites them to
apply
so this is an active approach rather
than a passive approach which is what
you get from a lot of other websites
in fact zip recruiters are so effective
that four out of five employers
who post unzip recruiter get a quality
candidate within the first day
uh you just can't beat that kind of
success so while other companies
overwhelm you with way too many options
zip recruiter finds
you what you're looking for the needle
and the haystack and right now you could
try zip recruiter for free at this web
address zip recruiter.com
walsh once again remember to go to this
unique place ziprecruiter.com
w-a-l-s-h zip recruiter the smartest way
to hire
all right so uh yeah so i am back from
vacation maybe you noticed
um sort of i'm actually taking another
few days around july 4th
but if you complain about that then
you then you're also an american this is
this this is my i think
part of my patriotic duty take a couple
days around july 4th uh but
it did it did go well especially
considering 20 drive ended up being 20
hours with
four kids and uh i'm not usually a
a guy who relies on on electronics with
the kids
in the car and all that but 20 hours i
thought okay we have a dvd player in the
car
we'll put the dvd on not the whole time
but um of course we get in the car the
dvd player is broken
so in spite of that it went well there
was there was one dust up
when we were at our vacation home on the
lake and my
my four-year-old son he
uh often when we're staying outside of
our house he gets nightmares i guess
because he's feeling a little
a little out of sorts a little homesick
so he got nightmares one night and he
comes into our room
and uh it's like three o'clock in the
morning and so i just let him sleep in
our room with us
which i knew it was a mistake because
then the next night he wants to do the
same thing and i'm saying no you got to
stay you got to stay in your own room
and he's worried about having nightmares
again so i'm sitting there talking to
him
and trying to you know figure out a
strategy to avoid nightmares and at
first i tell them well
if you start getting a nightmare just
remind yourself that you're in a dream
you know and and then and then you'll
wake up and i realize that's a bad
strategy because sometimes you can do
that where you realize you're dreaming
while you're dreaming but you can't
escape the dream and then it becomes
sort of an inception type of situation
which could be even more horrifying so
then i said okay why don't we j
just plan a good dream to have and i
said to him
think about what will be the if you
could go
anywhere in the world or do anything
what would it be
and he said he would want to go to a
candy store and i said well this is a
dream i mean you could be in a forest
where candy grows on the trees you could
be
there'd be candy falling from the sky
you don't need to go to an actual store
but he said no he wants to go to a candy
store and i said um
okay how much money do you want to have
in your dream in the can you could have
all the money
he said he wants to have a hundred
dollars i said you could have a bill you
could have 50 billion dollars in the
candy store
but all you wanted was 100. and so i
said just plan to dream of the candy
store with a hundred dollars
i will also dream about the candy store
and i'll meet you there in our dream and
then if any monsters show up i'll fight
them off and i'll protect you
and that was the plan but then um my
wife goes in to talk to him
and she he recruits her to be involved
in the dream too and then
he's talking to his sister and his
brother and now they're all
and now we're all coordinating this one
dream we're gonna have together it's way
too complicated
and i have the dream i'm at the candy
store and no one else shows up
they all went off somewhere else because
i get stood up even in my dreams i get
stood up by my own children
that's the moral of the story but other
than that it was a good vacation
now uh we uh we start here with a story
that i guess this happened on phrase
happened on friday so this is from a
report from nbc new york
says outrage mounted friday over
vandalism to new
to newly unveiled george floyd statues
in brooklyn
and newark new jersey as the former
minneapolis police officer accused of
murdering the 46-year-old father of five
was sentenced
to more than 22 years in prison a
punishment that some didn't believe was
harsh enough
uh yeah 22 22 years in prison you
probably heard that on fights what
that's what derek chovin was sentenced
to
yeah not harsh enough that's 22 years in
prison
because someone else died of a drug
overdose
that that's that's a pretty harsh
sentence for a drug overdose that
someone else had
a guy on four times a lethal dose of
fentanyl died of a drug overdose
and uh and you could send this 22 years
i would say it's pretty harsh
given the circumstances anyway back to
this report it says
many including tens of thousands in new
york city applauded the initial verdict
uh and frustration is growing as the
nypd's hate crimes task force searches
for the vandals who defaced the new
george floyd sculpture on flatbush
avenue
the vandalism to the flatbush statue
which was unveiled on flatbush avenue
last weekend amid the city's juneteenth
celebration
was discovered thursday morning uh they
said that what was the vandalism they
said that
that had much of the statute had been
painted black
the name of a group considered to be a
white nationalist hate group by the
southern poverty law center
always a reliable source on these things
was spray painted on the statue's
pedestal
and then another tribute to floyd
was also vandalized this in newark
the 700 pound bronze statue in newark
which debuted earlier this month outside
city hall had the face painted black
and then with the name of the same group
on the front of it
um and they're they're investigating
this as the article says as a hate crime
bill de blasio tweeted on friday he said
last night a far-right extremist group
vandalized the statue of george floyd in
brooklyn
a racist loathsome despicable act of
hate
the city cleanup corps is repairing the
statue right now and a hate crime
investigation is underway we will bring
these cowards to justice
now first of all i thought vandalizing
statues was
an acceptable form of peaceful protest
i thought that there's no such thing as
violence against property
isn't that what we heard for the whole
last year
this is this is them exercising their
free speech rights this is the precedent
that's been set if you don't like a
statue
you can deface it you could tear it down
i mean they should be they should be
happy that the george floyd statue was
only defaced
and not torn down set on fire and tossed
into a river as other statues have been
um but a couple of things to think about
here first of all
calling this a hate crime and calling it
racist
what is it a hate crime against a statue
who is it a hate crime against because
typically in a hate crime
and i'm not a big fan of the hate crime
designation i don't think it should
exist at all
but um but it
as i understand it usually in a hate
crime there has to be a victim
right someone is is a victim in a hate
crime
so who's the victim here it
george floyd is george floyd well he's
he's dead so he can't be the victim of a
hate crime
so who is it well i guess i can only
assume i i
the statue can't be the victim it's only
property
and by the way i'm sure it was insured
that's the other thing we learned as
long as as long as it has insurance then
uh you can
tear it down to whatever you want it
could burn down a cvs
as long as it has insurance but you
can't commit hate crime against a statue
uh
you can't commit a hate crime against
someone who's dead
so then then who is it against
and i guess it's a hate crime against
all black people is that what we're
supposed to understand
so george floyd is now a representative
of the entire black race is what we're
being told
in order for this to be a hate crime
that's that would have to be
you have to view it that way
what talk about racist talk about
loathsome and despicable
taking this guy and making him some sort
of
representative for a whole race
this guy george floyd
who who achieved precisely nothing of
value
in his entire life
as far as we know no one's ever told us
if he did anything of value or
significance we've never been told what
it is
the only thing of value and significance
that he achieved was when he died
and that was valuable and significant to
the left because they could exploit it
that's all they care about but as far as
how he actually lived his life
he did nothing except victimize other
people
he was a danger and a threat to his
community
um a violent felon a career criminal
a drug addict who died high on fentanyl
after trying to pass off bad checks
or a bad 20 bill
and you're making him um a
representative
i can tell you i that that's not what
what i would want
i wouldn't want to take some
some random criminal and make him a
representative for all white people i
wouldn't want that
you know the difference between every
time i talk about this
and why george floyd doesn't deserve
statues and monuments in fact i would
say
and i know there are a lot of uh there
are many
candidates for this title so i'm i'm a
little bit hesitant in saying it but
there's an argument you can make that
george floyd is
the most undeserving person to ever
have a statue built in his honor again i
know there are others you could point to
who are in the running but he's
he's certainly in the top five at least
as someone who did nothing of of
significance at all
and uh anytime i bring this up i'm
always i'm always told
well what about this or that
historical figure who was a problematic
and who
did bad things christopher columbus
thomas jefferson owns slaves and you
start going through the litany
right well
yeah see there's there's a difference
here we know that nobody is perfect
we know that great people who do great
things
very often have great flaws
and are also capable of and sometimes
and
and will commit great evil
we know that and if you are
set on only celebrating people who are
perfect
then you've really narrowed down your
list
so that's something that we know but the
difference is uh
that if we're talking about christopher
columbus
or thomas jefferson or many of these
other figures who have had their statues
torn down
they achieved great things they are
remembered by history for
what they for things that they actually
did
they changed the course of history
through their actions
while living
and in a good way
what about george floyd what did he do
nothing he broke into forced his way
into a woman's home and robbed her at
gunpoint in front of her child
that's as as far as we're aware of as
far as
with with george floyd's biography that
is the most significant thing he did
with his life
the most impactful thing he did with his
life was that
and i'm sure it made an enormous impact
on the woman who was victimized and her
child
of course nobody cares about her nobody
wonders how she must feel walking down
the street having to see a statue built
to the man
just imagine that imagine walking down
the street and seeing a literal
monument to a man who not but a few
years ago
was forcing his way into your home and
putting a gun to you
but nobody cares about her her voice is
uh silent
that's it that's the most significant
thing and then he died
and he died in a way that was that's
exploitable
for the left and that's all they care
about and that's why they build the
monument to him
there's there's a big difference all of
most of the other people who've had
statues torn down
even if even if they are guilty of some
of the atrocities they're accused of
and oftentimes they're not guilty of all
of the atrocities but even if they're
guilty of some of the
bad things they're accused of there is
no question that they achieved great
that they did great things with their
lives
that the world is different today
because of what they did with their life
and different in a good
way
all right um
so yeah george the george flight statues
should all be torn down
for tear down statues if we're tearing
down statues of violent oppressors
yeah let's do that let's start with
george floyd tear down the george floyd
statues and throw him in the river
he was a violent oppressor of women
and a bad person
all right let's go number two here
michael eric dyson speaking of bad
people
uh is an academic and intellectual and a
minister
and we need to put air quotes around all
of those descriptors but that's
how he describes himself and maybe you
saw this last week he was on
on msnbc and he attacked um
white conservatives calling them among
other things maggots
and we have an update to this story but
first let's play uh that clip of him
saying that here it is
and speaking about you know the maggots
i'm sorry the mega that
is so corrosive in this you know
political
uh moment i resent as an intellectual
and as a black person in america that we
have taken the brunt
of anti-intellectualism we have borne
the brunt
of being disloyal to this nation and we
have stood by
to see mediocre mealy-mouthed
uh snowflake white men who are incapable
of taking critique
who are willing to dole out infamous
repudiations
of the humanity of the other and yet
they call us snowflakes
and they are the biggest flakes of snow
to hit the earth
they are incapable of criticism they are
incapable of tolerating difference
they're scared of oh my god critical
race theory is going to kill your mother
and they don't even know they're not
critical they have no race
and they don't understand theory and yet
they are allowed to wax
eloquently about the means and
limits of rationality in this country
and they couldn't save themselves
if the world depended on it and i am
tired
of hearing mediocre white men uh
take to their pulpits to excoriate
women and trans people and bisexuals
and black folk and every other thing
that ain't them
it is time that we in america take back
this country
for certain and to seize the reigns of
authority
so that rhetorics of compassion
discourses
of empathy and love in the most radical
sense possible
would prevail rhetorics of compassion
discourses of empathy
by the way people who speak like this
are stupid
when they're speaking in a way where you
could tell they're trying to impress you
with their intelligence
um that's a sign of stupidity
rhetorics of compassion discourses of
empathy
nobody nobody talks like that
uh and putting aside the irony that
he he began by calling millions of
people
maggots snowflakes and
uh and and then he ends with with uh we
need more rhetoric's
rhetorics of compassion
we need more compassion from these
damned maggots
you know the problem with these filthy
disgusting worthless stupid maggots
they don't have compassion
they lack they lack kindness
rhetorics of compassion and i know this
isn't even the the main point here but i
also i i took note of uh
where he was talking about the the
mediocre mealy-mouthed
white men and uh once once again it goes
without saying
uh but i always say it every time that
if this was
a white guy on cable news
complaining about the quote mediocre
mealy-mouthed black men
we can imagine what the reaction would
be but it's okay for him to do
he's allowed to do that nobody can
explain why but he can't uh but
he says he's the mediocre white man who
is excoriating
bisexuals what
hey where have you ever heard a bisexual
be excoriated
who's doing that he also said that
transgender people and women are being
excluded that's not happening either but
bisexual is such a specific category to
choose here and i i've i've never
heard anyone get up on any pulpit
and say these you know what's problem in
america today these damn bisexuals
i've never heard anything like that ever
from anyone
uh but there was there he was and uh
with his with his his version of what a
rhetoric of compassion sounds like
and then he came back on msnbc a couple
days later
and sort of apologized for some of that
but not really let's listen
i myself yeah the other day let me let
me apologize on this program
i was trying to be cute and clever when
i was talking about magga
therefore mad gats not maggots i didn't
anticipate that
you know brothers and sisters who were
white would hear it as that so i deeply
and profoundly apologize for that
but i have been hit with an onslaught of
death threats and
being called the n word uh out of white
rage
uh for a mistake i made for which i am
willing to apologize certainly and
what black people are often up against
is the fact that we have to be told that
a motion will not judge will not lead um
our uh you know offering of justice to
you emotion will not drive
or a statement to be made to the
american public would not drive what we
do legally
and yet so much emotion is directed at
us so much hatred is directed at us
so much white rage is directed at us
yeah every part of that is total
nonsense
first of all he says it was a it was a
mistake i didn't i didn't anticipate
that anyone would take it that way what
uh no i called him maggots by i didn't i
didn't know that anyone
would think that i was caught
i all he did was call you a maggot i
didn't think that you would
think that i was calling you a maggot
what do you what did you mean to say
um so he's not taking ownership at all
there's there's no real apology there at
all but then
and then and then of course we always
hear about i've got the onslaught of
death threats you know what show me the
receipts
uh michael because i i don't or whatever
your name is yeah michael
show me the receipts on that i get tired
of people always talking about
we always hear this anytime someone's
getting criticized
they say i've been getting death threats
for the last have you really
maybe you have but uh but show me the
receipts on that
i want i want to see the death threats
because i do get death threats um
and when i get them i i do show the
receipts i'll show you what they look
like
it's it's relatively rare what's what's
a lot more common
that i get all the time are people
wishing death on me saying
go kill yourself and that kind of thing
which is a horrible thing to say to a
person
but i don't call that a death threat so
anytime someone claims that they're
dealing with an
onslaught of death threats and so you
imagine like
hundreds of people threatening to kill
them
yeah i gotta say i don't really believe
it could could be
maybe it happened i don't know but in
either case
when you not that a death threat would
be justified
but when you get up on national tv and
you call millions of people
maggots you're going you're gonna get an
angry response
it doesn't matter who you're what that
whatever group you're targeting with
that comment
they're gonna be angry and they're gonna
let you know that they're angry
and since it's the internet they're
gonna let you know in hyperbolic terms
but now he's the victim all i did was
call
millions of people maggots i didn't
anticipate all this anger
and you know this is the problem anytime
a black man speaks up in america
he has to deal with white rage yeah if a
black man
calls people maggots he's gonna have to
deal with rage just like if a white man
did it he'd also have to deal with rage
that tends to enrage people people tend
to get upset about that
most people when you call them a maggot
they're not gonna
laugh about it or say well you're
entitled to your opinion
you believe i'm a maggot i don't think i
am but we'll let bygones be bygones
now on the internet you can't even i
say what your favorite flavor of ice
cream is without people
taking it as a personal attack so if you
call them maggots
how do you think anyone's gonna respond
but he gets he gets close to the
precipice of an apology
and then turns right back around and
says uh never mind you know what
actually i'm the victim
and it's okay he'll get away with it
even the the non-apology that he gave
was uh not even actually necessary
because no one's going to hold him
accountable and
he can still appear on cable news and
he's not going to lose any jobs or you
know if he's
i don't know what he if he works for a
university or something they're not
going to get rid of them
so there's no accountability there at
all all right
a couple other things i wanted to
mention
we got to do yeah maybe we'll say this
for a moment because we also have the
the ufo report
but you know what i was going to skip
over it because i am
this is the moment i've been wait as you
know i've been waiting for this moment
i bought the t-shirts i had the
merchandise
my whole life leading up to this moment
and uh and then the the the much
anticipated
ufo report is released and
uh basically it's
it's not even worth going over because
it's everything that we already knew
so if there's any headline from the ufo
report
um it's that uh reading now from the
daily wire it says
the director of national intelligence on
friday released a highly anticipated
report outlining what the government
knows so far about unidentified flying
objects
and the threat they pose but it offered
scant conclusions about such phenomena
the dni announced friday afternoon that
it has submitted a preliminary report to
congress on the progress that the u.s
navy's
unidentified aerial phenomena task force
has made in understanding
unidentified aerial phenomena more
commonly known as ufos
the intelligence report said this i
guess is really the headline the only
headline
the intelligence report said that u.s
intelligence cannot explain 143 of the
144 cases of ufos observed
and reported by military aircraft from
2004 to 2021.
the one incident that they could
categorize with certainty was identified
as a large deflating balloon
but i don't know how isn't a large
deflating balloon rather
rather easy to identify why was it in
the report at all
but the others remain unexplained so
that's kind of it
i was hoping
that in the report you know
they would confirm aliens are real and
they're among us
and they're standing right next to you
that's what i was hoping the report
would say
was that a delusional hope
you know was that the hope of a of a of
a
of a deluded and and pretty stupid
individual
yes but even so
i wait for months and this is what i get
yeah i guess this is kind of i'm now
experiencing the letdown
that people feel i guess when a new star
wars comes out
i never quite understood that as a as an
as a as a non-star wars fan as someone
who recognizes that all the star wars
movies are bad anyway
i've never quite felt or experienced
the anger and disappointment and let
down that everyone feels every time new
star wars comes out and
you have all this anticipation that it
doesn't live up to the hype at all i
feel that way about this
because this was supposed to be the real
star wars
and uh just didn't work didn't happen
all right we're gonna but one more here
report from the nbc affiliate in orlando
um says president joe biden is
celebrating pride month with a series of
activities a reflection of the growing
stature of the lgbtq community at the
white house
on friday biden signed into law a
measure designating
the pulse nightclub as a national
memorial
the shooting at pulse in 2016 was the
deadliest attack on the lgbtq community
in u.s history biden made the
announcement
of the designation on the fifth
remembrance of the deadly shooting
the president emphasized that the
country must do more to reduce gun
violence such as banning assault weapons
and closing loopholes and regulations
um and then the uh the one pulse
foundation said in a statement quote
today is a major milestone in fulfilling
the mission of the national pulse
memorial museum
it is so meaningful to everyone here
especially in families of the 49
survivors first responders
and all the lives affected it's also a
clear and lasting message to the lgbtq
plus community that what happened at
pulse matters and will never be
forgotten for future generations
and that we will always outlove hate
out love hate now we should mention
um because it matters because it's the
truth
that this connection that they're trying
to make now and that biden is sort of
implying
um and that we hear in the media
between anti-gay hate and the pulse
nightclub shooting
that connection is is not real uh the
killer
there's as far as we know and has ever
been determined this shooting had
nothing to do with anti-gay
hate at all in fact the killer was
himself
gay according to people close to him
anyway and he himself
said that he was motivated by revenge
for drone attacks in the middle east
and what we learned from investigators
early on is that he had a couple of
targets in mind um one happened to be
the gay nightclub and then there was
another bar nightclub in town that he
was he was kind of deciding between the
two and he decided on a whim that it was
going to be
the pulse nightclub that doesn't make it
any less horrific
obviously um
but this is what we get from the left or
from democrats
they can't stick with the simple facts
just say that it was a a horrible
travesty a massacre
there any negative adjective meant most
of the negative adjectives that you
could use
would apply here except it's not an
anti-gay hate crime that doesn't make it
any
better okay you get to a certain level
this is one of my problems
one of the problems i have with the hate
crime designation you get to a certain
level
where an act is so evil
and so horrible that it can't possibly
be worse
so we get the hate crime designation
we're trying to parse
uh well was this was was the person
motivated by hate where they motivate
why does it even matter look at what
they did
in terms of condemning it in terms of of
of punishing the the perpetrator if
they're still
alive
what does it matter what motivated it
it's obviously can't be motivated by
anything good
but also and i'm afraid i just have to
point this out at the ceremony i wanted
to show you
jill biden the good doctor
just wanted to show you this i'll put
this up on the screen you see the dress
that she's uh wearing
at uh i believe this was the same
ceremony
and you see that i don't know what's
happening here in this dress it looks
like she was caught in a tornado
inside of a joanne fabrics
it's like she got assaulted by all of
the curtains in my grandmother's house
at one time
i i don't know what who i'm not someone
who
notices most of the time you've got to
make a really outrageous
fashion choice for me to notice how bad
it is
and i just see that like what do you
think especially at a solemn occasion
like this
wearing a dress like that a memorial
where 49 people died and that's the
dress you put on i don't know but all
jokes aside i mean jill biden i guess is
showing what equity and inclusion is all
is all about by uh hiring a blind man to
make her dress so i guess we should
um at least be grateful for that now
when it comes to clothing my
my main priority is uh is comfort i want
to be comfortable in what i'm wearing
for my wife though she cares more about
style for me what it looks like she has
to just look at me so i can't understand
where she's coming from
and that could create some tension
sometimes but we found a happy
compromise in mac weldon because with
mac weldon you get comfort you also get
style and it's very effortless
mac weldon has everything you could
possibly look for they have all the
basics
their full collection includes t-shirts
polos button-ups shorts pants
swimsuits so much more anything you want
they've got it mack weldon
and especially this summer as we get
into some of the summer activities
you've got to check out mac weldon's
collections they've got swimsuits
if you're not in the pool they've got
their maverick tech chino short and
radius short are the perfect additions
to your summer wardrobe whatever you're
doing if you're going you're working out
if you're going to work
if you're going out on a date whatever
it is you're doing mac weldon has
something for you
mac weldon also has a free loyalty
program called weldon blue
level one gets you free shipping for
life once you reach level two by
spending 200 bucks you get 20
off every order for the next year so for
20 off your first order visit
macweldon.com
wall schneider promo code walsh that's
mackweldon.com
walls promo code walls for 20 off mack
weldon
reinventing men's basics you know here
at the daily wire we love history to be
specific we love history that isn't
censored in order to adhere to the
accepted narrative currently dominating
american culture
that's why we're all huge fans of the
documentary created equal the film
follows supreme court justice clarence
thomas on his journey from the
segregated south to
sitting at the highest court in the land
uh which
he was by the way only the second black
american to accomplish
you don't hear about that as much for
obvious reasons
but um and lucky for you the daily wire
is now streaming it the documentary is
not only available to daily wire members
so if you uh or rather it is only
available to daily wire members so if
you
want more stories that diverge from the
accepted political narrative
and that's something i know we all want
you got to go to dailywire.com
subscribe to get 20 off your new
membership with code
justice again if you don't want to be
stuck with uh with
what you get out there from corporate
media
if you want to get the important stories
that are well told and the ones you need
to hear you got to go to dailywire.com
subscribe 20 off your new membership
with codejustice
now let's get to our daily cancellation
a couple of weeks ago pixar released its
newest film
a coming-of-age tale about two young
boys in italy who
spend a summer getting into mischief
going on adventures discovering the true
meaning of friendship etc
the twist is that both of the boys luca
and alberto are actually sea monsters
and when they venture in
onto dry land they assume the appearance
of human beings but whenever they're in
the water
they revert back to their true sea
monster form this
apparently is the plot now not to give
away the ending but
eventually everybody on land learns that
the boys are actually sea monsters and
things get a little hairy at first but
then they all learn to accept luca and
alberto for who they are
while more importantly luca and alberto
learn to accept
themselves and i don't need to see the
movie to tell you it ends that way
almost every kid's movie since the dawn
of time
has been at some level a coming-of-age
story and there's almost always
prominent themes of self-acceptance of
being yourself and so on
pixar isn't doing anything new here even
the sea monster bit is clearly
reminiscent of the little mermaid a
disturbing tale about a monstrous
aquatic freak who crawls onto land and
stalks a young prince
eventually ensnaring him in a romantic
relationship on false pretenses
the only thing that's arguably unique
about luca
is that the film centers around male
friendship there there is no romance
here
um unlike in little mermaid now when i
was growing up
those kinds of stories were a little
more common the sandlot is one example
i was a big fan of that movie as a kid
but these days
most movies feel the need to shoehorn in
some kind of romance angle and of course
there always
has to be at least as many female
protagonists as male
luca slightly breaks from that mold it
seems by telling a more simple
innocent straightforward story of two
young boys who become friends
but nothing is allowed to be simple and
innocent and straightforward anymore
not when there is so much indoctrinating
to be done and so little time to do it
and that's why
many people on the lgbt left and the
media have spent the last several days
insisting
that luca must in fact be a gay movie
it's not a gay movie the boys are not
gay
and there's no romance between them
which is good because the characters are
prepubescent children
we're not yet at the point where pixar
will release a movie about
eight-year-old boys in love
we may get there eventually but for some
on the left that time can't come soon
enough they're
impatient and that's why if you go to
twitter and you search for luca right
now
you'll find many tweets like this from a
guy named eric rosewood
or rosswood i think self-professed lgbt
activist and author of the book the
ultimate guide for gay dads
and he tweeted quote just saw luca and i
don't care what anyone else says
it's the first gay animated film by
disney pixar
feeling like you might have have to hide
a part of yourself meeting someone you
like for the first time
strangers calling you and your friends
monsters finding the good ones
i cried now he's not alone in this
assessment
a headline from buzzfeed says i'm sorry
but luca is totally a gay movie
and that's why i loved it so much screen
rant announces
why luca is an lgbtq story despite what
pixar says
the av club has a lengthy miss of
explaining its genuis detail
why the gay interpretation of luca is
entirely valid
and vanity fair takes a more sort of
middle-of-the-road approach with its
contribution to this discussion
the headline is luca pixar's first gay
movie
maybe we should note meanwhile that the
director of the film
who may be considered an authority on
what the movie is about
has addressed these claims and clarified
that no it's not a gay thing
the boys are just friends boys are
allowed to be friends
in fact most boys have friends who are
boys
and there's nothing sexual about it this
is quite normal and healthy
what is not normal and healthy is to see
all male friendship even prepubescent
fictional animated male friendship
through a sexual lens
the insider uh website has taken a
different approach
accepting that luca is not a gay story
and castigating pixar for lacking the
courage
to sexualize a relationship between two
elementary age children the author
jacob sarkeesian he writes quote while
the implications of queerness are there
particularly in the friendship between
luke and alberto it's disappointing that
disney's pixar wasn't brave enough to
fully commit to their first
queer animated tale he continues luca is
immediately taken by the free-spirited
alberto
when that when he meets a fellow sea
monster off the coast of
puerto rosso they're casually physical
with one another sleeping side by side
under a star-filled sky
wrapping their arms around each other's
waists and watching the sunset together
in fact they spent a lot of time
embracing one another teasing that their
relationship could blossom
into something more the comparisons to
call me by your name a film where two
young men fall in love
are well earned the italian seaside
setting the hazy beauty of the summer
scenery
and the tale of two boys experiencing
love for the first time
now sarkeesian begrudgingly accepts that
the nine-year-olds in the cartoon
aren't sexually interested in each other
it's just that he's disappointed
is all he says this may seem refreshing
to some to see
a disney movie explore friendship as
opposed to a fairy tale love story
but it's a shame this decision has come
when a gay romance could have so easily
and naturally been explored
making luca and alberto explicitly gay
or queer wouldn't have felt contrived
it would have been a meaningful
confirmation of what is already a story
rich in gay
subtext yes why tell
any other kind of story when you could
have so easily told a gay one
why does a sylvester stallone fight carl
weathers and rocky when they could have
been gay lovers instead
why is apollo 13 about an aborted lunar
mission when it could have been a
romance between
two gay astronauts on mars a kind of
brokeback mountain in space
type of thing and by the way i hope
you'll admire my restraint in refraining
from making a uranus joke
right here i'm not doing that but why
should any story
be told if it's not a mechanism for
sexual indoctrination
why should anything exist if it's not
ideologically useful to progressives
these are the questions that torment our
friends on the left
and the questions are all the more
disturbing when applied to a movie about
eight or nine-year-old boys um
it's bad enough for them to sexualize
children as they do
but now they're offended when children
are not sexualized
the writer of that insider article is
experiencing something like
moral indignation at the fact that a
couple of prepubescent cartoon
characters
aren't depicted in an explicitly sexual
embrace
i'd really hate to see what sort of
improvements quote unquote this weirdo
would make
to those stories of male friendship that
i grew up watching
don't let them anywhere near the sand
lot that's all i can say
don't let them anywhere near an actual
sandlot either if there are kids on it
the implications here go beyond movies
and cartoons the real point for these
leftists with their half-baked
freudian notions is that all people are
driven primarily by sexual impulses
and this includes children to them in
their
dark pedophilic vision of reality
innocent platonic friendships don't
exist can't exist
they see two boys with their arms around
each other and they think well why would
anyone behave this way unless it's for
sexual reasons
no other kind of love no other sort of
bond
can or should be formed and this kind of
over
sexualization of everything makes it
more difficult for boys in reality to
form those platonic loving bonds with
each other
when we hear so much about a lack of
representation in film
well male friendship is not represented
very
represented very often or very well and
so boys are not provided with examples
of what those relationships look like
and here we see part of the reason why
pixar can't even put out a movie about a
couple of sea monsters becoming friends
without leftists trying to drape a
rainbow flag over the whole thing
and for that reason they are of course
all of them together
very much cancelled and that'll do it
for us today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadosky
the show is edited by sasha tolmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by nikka geneva and
our production coordinator is mckenna
waters
the matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 21.
today on the ben shapiro show new
polling shows democrats behind on nearly
every major issue
but democrats can't stop doubling down
on stupid anyway that's today on the
bench bureau show give it a listen